i noticed that you said you're you're
talking about your father and i'm sure
he's amazing man
but
every time you said
he doesn't drink he doesn't cheat
you said he's such a wonderful person
i would argue
that if i'm honest enough to tell the
truth
and i support
the other half and i kill myself trying
to make her life wonderful then i also
am an amazing person yeah and so you
weren't a good person no i'm just saying
just for because of contrast sake i'm
not upset about it okay look i get
called a piece of [ __ ] all the time so
no it's fine i mean yeah yeehaw
but what i what i am saying is like
being a good person
and being monogamous are two different
things
your father
and rolo tomasi
and donovan sharp
are a product of a zeitgeist that is
about let's say 20 30 years back
and that's where everybody came up and
believed and lived and died by the sword
of the bible mostly
that monogamy was only way if your
father being a one percenter or rolo or
donovan
were 35 now here now in 2022 with
instagram and women blowing their phone
up all day i argue that the likelihood
of them being monogamous for 25 30 years
is substantially less
not because
they're weaker not because of anything
other than
each generation faces a new set of
problems
and those gentlemen including your
father and respect
don't or never did had to face the
problems let's say the gentlemen of
today have to
face when it comes to temptation against
the natural nature of biology as a human
being i also think it's again as i've
said the situations you choose to put
yourself in
so again including the year you're born
and in the culture
no but i like because you're not
relevant if you're not on social media
right now
you're not relevant yeah like someone
like in business if you're trying to
like build yourself up in business
linkedin facebook like a lot of our
business card is on our instagram how
people perceive us treat us and allow us
to have opportunity in the market yeah
but you have to understand like
this is a very different industry than
what my dad does
he's fine without social media i get
metal building deals because of
instagram okay
i'm just saying i'm just saying like
like
your dad yeah he sounds like a superhero
because even he is one percent from his
time
right
but i think there's it's important that
somebody watching this
understands the distinction respectfully
the distinction between what your father
chose to do with his life and being a
good person well i just when i hear that
someone chooses to be loyal like to be
entered into a monogamous relationship
with the woman that gave him seven
biological kids three adopted and
chooses to be monogamous i just have a
different level of respect for it i just
i then than someone that chooses to like
exercise their options do you understand
that most monogamous monogamous men are
not loyal let me tell you why
the evidence doesn't really support that
if you take surveys but i think usually
the red pill is like like they're just
lying but let's talk about let's talk
about
let's talk about loyalty though okay
because most men that get married
use
marriage and monogamy as a mating
strategy to get that woman
okay so he's trading sexual exclusivity
for
and marriage
for sex
but he makes vows
that he's going to do his best to create
the most wonderful life he can for that
woman
they exchange vows
and in my opinion a man's loyalty is
keeping that second part
when most men don't they come home they
pop open a beer they smoke a bowl of
weed they watch a ball game they turn on
an xbox
no and okay
as they do that they do not produce and
provide for their woman and i would
argue that is the most unloyal man that
you can possibly come in contact with
because he stood in front of people and
made vows to take care of her provide
for her and create an amazing life for
her and he came home and popped open a
bud light that's not loyalty no i i
agree with you i i do like i always say
i think cheating is different for men
and for women i always say i i would
leave someone if they cheated unless we
had kids because if you have kids it's
not about you anymore but
i i just think it's cool like i just
respect my dad a lot for having the
option to do what he does and still
choosing to remain loyal to my mom and i
know the red pill will say forever oh
he's cheating he's cheating but but i
don't know my dad is just i respect him
a lot and i think it's really cool that
he does that i think there's a good
chance that there's a relationship that
your mother and your father have between
them that you'll never know about i'm
not saying he's cheating
but
if he did cheat
he's a damn good man from hiding it from
all of you so he can continue to paint
that picture of reality now me
i'm not going to do that because i would
rather live in truth
but if you know how they say if a tree
falls in the woods nobody hears it did
it happen
maybe that zeitgeist that group of men
in that age range that was their
strategy now that we're in 2022
the strategy i think that it makes you
the best man shows the most character is
to just tell the truth hey just tell the
truth and don't embarrass your woman i i
agree with you but i i just don't like
the argument that like
everybody doesn't feel good to you no
it's not that it doesn't feel good it's
that you'll believe what you believe
regardless of any evidence to the
contrary so if the evidence says that
one out of four men cheat you'll say oh
they all cheat
i would argue and it's like if i say no
my dad doesn't cheat he doesn't do that
you say well he probably has an
arrangement with your mom behind the
scenes because i'm not saying that i'm
not saying that i'm saying there's a
chance you you just you just implied
that which is fine like i understand
that's your world view but i just grew
up around like
i would say like the men of value versus
high value men which is just like the
type of men that kind of get their money
get their woman go buy a piece of land
and don't want to talk to anybody and
it's just a very different like world
than the like one that you guys live in
and that's partially what brought me
into the red pill because i was like
this is what you think high value men
are like right and that's kind of what
i'm arguing yeah because because you're
just you're putting
certain life choices
with value as a person
and i'm simply saying what created value
in his time and certainly in your life
because obviously you've turned out very
very well
him being valuable in that time and him
having that good impact on you is
incredible i'm just simply arguing that
a man that in 2022 that tells the truth
takes care of his business takes care of
his family shows up for his wife in the
most important ways providing truly
loving her making sure that her life is
a [ __ ] carpet ride and then loving
the [ __ ] out of the kids and supporting
and doing the right thing that a man
should do because a man does have the
burden of performance and i put that
burden of performance
right there in the loyalty spot
in the turning up for your family that
is a good man
not whether you had sex with another
woman or whatever you know it's the
lying
it's the deceit that hurts so badly
and the reason that women are unhappy
is because the formula for happiness is
the gap between expectation and reality
yeah your father gave that to your
mother that's what made him a good man
for me i would rather not lie because
the world has changed since your father
was a father and from when i will be a
father so i'm going to be brave enough
old enough to love and be impactful
enough to tell the truth and you can
leave if you want
but if you leave me for a man you love
less when i told you the truth you have
to respect that i tell you the truth and
then i back up what i said and that
loyalty is producing performing
providing and being who you say you are